agent peacock
talks to the real michael shanahan who
realizes he's a victim of identity theft
credit cards and checking accounts have
been taken out in his name
and then there's the statue that cox
left behind at shanahan's house
pours salt in his wounds
you dirt bag listen man i mean let me
tell you about the statue
that that is listen fraud's not a
full-time thing okay
it's if we [ __ ] a lot of down time
we're doing
rock climbing we're [ __ ] we're going
hiking we're
jogging we're running we're just [ __ ]
we're doing anything to to
so i make this paper mache statue of a
man
screaming and ago screaming and acting
like nothing to do with it like he's on
fire or something
what are you doing what are you doing
honestly it's not that's not pointing it
out i'm just saying it's a
it's a statue anyway so what happens is
when i when we go to leave and we're
packing up our stuff
i can't fit the statue in the [ __ ]
car or in the the the van that we've got
yeah so i have to leave the we even we
took out the talk
i'm sorry we take out the back thing
like the back seat
yeah we just can't pack everything in so
becky's like we're gonna have to leave
it
like a big like astro van or something
like that no minivan
like a minivan it was like a like a
honda element or something oh okay
so i have to leave it so i leave
it and i we leave the back um
the the back seat in the garage
when i when this guy shows up at my
sentencing
he says that one we trash the house i'm
not sure how we trashed the house we had
the carpets cleaned
it was in as good a shape as it was when
we left i mean when we moved in
i only had a bedroom set we didn't buy
furniture
we had nothing we had a [ __ ] bedroom
set
and and it's just the two of us we've
been there a month or so or maybe we've
been there a few months
so this thing
i leave in the garage he says i left it
in the
living room and then when he walked in
the house it was in the living room
and the whole house was trashed trashed
with what we don't have anything
it wasn't trashed and it was in the
garage
not that i'm saying what i did was right
what i'm saying is it's always like it's
like i always
picture him like hiking it in and
sitting it down and
staging the whole thing to you know and
try like trashing that
it wasn't trash but anyway yeah but the
the statue so it's he turns it into
it was he was taunting me he was
taunting you bro
you think i i worked [ __ ] hours and
hours
right you think i didn't want to bring
my statue i specially would love to redo
that statue
you should i never auction it off
that would be great okay sorry all right
let's go
he told me that he felt like he was
leaving it behind
on purpose because that was the way he
felt when he saw that statue and
realized what cox had done to him
he felt like he was mocking him that's
that's
i do owe him money he'd want to leave he
paid he had to pay an
attorney he ended up having to pay an
attorney like four thousand dollars
um and the attorney contacted all the
title insurance companies and had them
pay off all the you know those loans got
paid off and everything so
and those got those guys so instead of
just him calling and talking to
the two guys that they just interviewed
like hey look what happened okay my name
is
i'm not really michael i'm not the real
michael shanahan here's what happened
instead of doing that he hired an
attorney that did all that for him and
that was about four grand okay
and i own that um documents
just as a trail to see this is what i've
done he's just like
try and catch me you can't flush with
cash cox and hawk go on a spending spree
i went from having absolutely no money
to having money
and even now i think god i wasted a lot
of money
on nonsense the chick has been so far
hawk
is obsessed with clothes and jewelry
matt cox is all about fast carbs
and breast implants i didn't i didn't
need them
i mean i was fine everything was fine
like i said no complaints whatsoever
from anybody else but he was
always wanted this kind of trophy person
and of course me i'm like yes if this is
going to make you happy let me you know
let me do this
what are you serious i could what the
first of all she already had [ __ ]
boobs i don't understand what
she got a boob job that she got a move
job
and and she look you know what happened
[ __ ] listen
we we ended up stealing a bunch of money
she you know what
no this is when she got it that's true
we
we got a bunch of money and so i was
going to have
400 and change right yeah it was it was
almost 400 000 okay roughly they said
300 000. there's like 400 yeah um
i said look i'm gonna get this done yeah
you know i'm gonna get [ __ ] rhino
platinum and get my [ __ ] nose done
and get a [ __ ] facelift i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get a bunch of [ __ ] done
just because it ain't good bro my
[ __ ] picture's everywhere we're in
where they got all kinds of [ __ ]
happening
you're turning on now we're going on the
internet and this [ __ ] my picture's
everywhere now
not that you're gonna find me because
you don't you don't know my name but
it's bad
so i was like i'm gonna [ __ ] change
this and this and then she's she's she's
like i want i want a [ __ ] boob job
i'm like [ __ ] yeah if you want a boob
job get a boob job
give a [ __ ] i don't even want to be
around this [ __ ] broad
she's driving me nuts so she's she's
bipolar she wouldn't take the medication
she gets on the medication a couple
times she gets the cops called on me
multiple times because she's screaming
at two o'clock in the morning
she's a [ __ ] lunatic so
she said she would take the medication
for like a month and it would start to
work and then she would get off it
because she said
i felt like well i would i'm i'm okay
now you're okay night kills you're
taking the medication
but she didn't like the way it made her
feel and it was the only thing keeping
her sane
got it so so this is the point where you
go and spend a shitload of money getting
your face
all re-remodeled right so i just do the
hair
thing done so that's why i don't have
that receding hairline and
the nose job because my nose was round
real round and
um should have got [ __ ] some some
some leg implants or something some
[ __ ] you should try to i looked i
looked into it but
but she would have had to have watched
me for like three months i can't have
her watching
you would have been immobilized are you
serious
you saw misery right i mean now i can't
have her watching me she [ __ ] come in
with a baseball bat or something and
beat my at
oh absolutely not i mean you don't know
she look you look at her right now
thinking oh she looks
she's cute she's sweet [ __ ] lunatic
um so yeah did not ask her to get a boob
job but
to be honest they did do excellent work
it was it was it was a swan institute
and yeah and
it's called the swan institute and uh in
uh in atlanta and they did they did
excellent work
good i'm just saying in general nice and
firm yeah they were nice you know they
were you know
even and so i ended up going to the
doctor
and getting that done matt cox treats
his girlfriend's body as a canvas he can
paint
or twist to fit his fantasies [ __ ]
he does the same appearance when we left
he got obsessed with the way he looked
and how his physique was and stuff like
that i mean he went he hardly ever ate
he had a nose job done
life was done under here he had it done
on his side
so he had yeah he had a lot of surgeries
all of it of course is paid with money
stolen from his victims
i don't know what would motivate someone
to do that greed is the first thing that
you think of
uh but there was more than greed i think
there was a big dose of ego involved in
this crime for this particular
individual
it was the rush it was the thrill of the
chase
and he thought he could get away with it
forever but at that point i really did i
thought
they'll never catch me american greed
returns
way off see how the law catches up with
cops
i'm freaking out and now cox escapes
i